huh
dude
[Music]
hey got a second
I'm looking for ruins specifically a
door
[Music]
why you need to close this door right
gates open in lonely places where no
human hearts remain
and from those Gates
disaster comes
away goodbye
what the hell is going on
maybe you should be worrying more about
yourself
what you came looking for a cat all the
way from Kyushu
people will die
a whole lot of them
all right then I need you to lock the
door
you were right I can't do it
as I fear so to fail didn't it
that much at least should frighten you a
world without soda terrifies me
[Music]
I could never forget I promise I'll come
save you you guys get a life of his own
to worry about I get the feeling that
whatever you're doing it's super
important I return them to you
I'll see you I'll see ya
I'll see you